people saying no we're not giving up our
AR-15 so even whether you want to look
at it from from advocating in terms of
civil rights advocating just on guns
we're arming bigots Al Sharpton is Right
gun control is a civil rights issue but
not the way he claims gun control is
racist and has historically been used to
disarm minority groups here's proof in
1831 Virginia made it illegal for free
black people to keep her carry firearms
after a slave Uprising New York
implemented Firearms licensing
requirements in 1911 after race riots as
recent as the late' 60s California
banded the open carry of loaded guns as
a response to Armed black panther
patrols so would new gun control laws
Advance civil rights no definitely not
that's a hard pass black people
represent 14% of the US population yet
accounted for 45% of weapons arrests in
2020 crime rates among demographic
groups explain some of this disparity
but not all of it similar to drug war
arrest data we know that black Americans
are more likely to be arrested and
charged than white Americans in similar
circumstances so you can advocate for
civil rights or you can advocate for gun
control but it's contradictory to
advocate for both